you
these are the new iphone iphone 6 iphone
meals and the iphone 6 was they are
without a doubt how does the iphones
we've ever done so let me know she legit
but i hopes you'll agree what says
you're the best phone who has ever tell
you all about them i'd like to invite
phil schiller
good morning everyone and welcome back
why you play though I am honored
represent the whole team's be the one to
tell you about these incredible new
iphone no Kyle what's the Eiffel they're
designed like nothing everybody edible
unique should do you are that from the
glass front it's all buddies birds
around the side to be seamlessly facial
she anodized aluminum back hi yohji
close is still out it is we woke up the
most beautiful phony I've ever seen and
from the start the team is envisioned
the new iphone 6 would come with to
display sizes Oh chica I don't know
where your layout but not any display
will do these are our new generations
Retina display we call them reps HD
retina HD cuz they are by far the most
beautiful displays ever built into a
phone there are news in every way please
Josh it's incredibly bright cheats or
colors are stunning they're accurate
srgb accurate yeah that's GP and across
and the top to the bottom the team has
worked hard to make them at best we know
how from there I unspent the glass all
the way down new thinner back lights so
packed with incredible innovations I'll
just give you one example okay the LCD
TLC displays all your beautiful colored
photos it's made with the technology
called dual domain pixels and these pics
was allowing a very broad angle of view
of accurate color is simply stunning I
like any display ever run across all
Dustin there's other people there bigger
JC yeah I'd say the pier a lot bigger
okay the text is incredible to even
sharper and more of it you can see your
the message is that yes 16 weighs more
than before x plus displays morn as
extra room there so we've put your
friends faces like this when you turn
them in landscapes we show more as well
and we took special advantage of the
iphone 6 plus because of all those
pixels
some new things with our round starts so
for example the messages out in a legend
new horizontal to up this way your
weather shows more of your day Stark's
those new clothes wants to get a great
horizontal view now with two rotting
mail since has two ups i can see your
inbox message was when you bring up the
keyboard in any of your wraps with the
iphone 6 plus the keyboard takes
advantage of the display area to give
you some more keys for example dedicated
keys for cut copy and paste that is even
a new horizontal whole screen view if
you like to work this way with a dock
along the right here cohen sound like us
or higher everything grapes example
advantage of these huge displays that's
more capable that